Psst, yo. Yeah, you dumbass. You got $100 on ya? Um, cuz I need it. I can do something
in return, mister. I'm a good girl. I can, like, offer my services. What kind? Eh, good
question. Let me think. Well, we're in this dark and dingy alleyway, in a scrupulous part
of town, so the only logical thing that I can do in return for an exchange of money is...
ASMR, of course. Duh. Well, come on. If you've got the cash, it's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity.
I mean, who else is gonna offer you it? Are you telling me there's cute and funny girls
throwing themselves at you to tingle you? Exactly. So hurry up and hand it over already.
I love people who make it easy. Thanks. Um, alright. Let's see what I have on me that I can use to
make you tingle. Hmm. Oh, this'll do. It's my little plastic tube. You know that whole thing
where girls like cute small things? It's true. Like stationery, for example. The smaller the
cuter, and thus the better. That's why I have this little plastic paper clip holder.
Okay. Now ain't over. You're too tall for me to do this one.
Alright, so if each tingle is worth $5, then I only need to do this. 1, 2, 3, 4, 18 more times.
Oh, what? I don't even have enough things with me to do that. I'm gonna have to get really creative
with this. Oh, there's a glass bottle in the ground. What? Don't give me that look. It's
good to be resourceful. You know that, right? See? I can make do with this ear to ear. You
can't tell me that's not tingle ready with a straight face.
I could bite joke you? What? It's a tingle. I swear it is. Do you not want YouTube videos
or something? Goth roleplays are pretty popular at the moment. It's your $100. If you don't
want it, then fine. I'll think of something else. Ha, got ya.
Some cotton balls came out of my voodoo doll recently. I can repurpose it for now.
And if you enjoyed that sound, I can also do this too.
Then there's the super basic stuff like finger flittering. It's a bit boring, but I can mix
in some ear tapping too.
Oh, you have a request? And what would that be, mister? Of course I can run my fingers
through your hair. You made me nervous thinking it was something a little more explicit that
I do have tissues. I could try this. Have you been keeping count, by the way? I was starting
to lose track of how long I've been doing this for.
Maybe you like the sound of scratching? Yeah, like that. What do you think? It's good, right?
I suppose I can take my pins out to brush through your hair as well, but only because
you didn't make a fuss when handing over the money. You'd be surprised how many people
only want to pay me after the service.
Um, not to alarm you or anything, but you're starting to slouch over now. I think you're
passing out. You want more? Are you sure you can even handle more, though? I have a few
more things I could do then, but I'm going to need to get going soon.
This is the last one, sadly, but I'm really thankful for your business. You never know.
If you walk through here again, we could do this, and I'll actually be more prepared next
time, but I'll be quiet while you enjoy this last one.
I have to get going now, but thanks again for your patronage. Maybe I'll see you again
next time. Good night, mister.